IT IS CURRENTLY ONLY 35%
CONTAINED.
>> Bill: TWO MAJOR STORIES OUT
OF CHINA TODAY.
THE GOVERNMENT INTRODUCING A
NEW WAVE OF LOCKDOWNS, COVID
VARIANT HAS TAKEN HOLD IN
CITIES INCLUDING THE 11 MILLION
POPULATED TOWN OF WUHAN.
OFFICIALS THERE REPORTING LESS
THAN TWO DOZEN CASES SO FAR.
OTHERS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
MICHAEL PILLSBURY, HUDSON
INSTITUTE DIRECTOR OF CHINESE
STRATEGY AND AUTHOR OF THE 100
YEAR MARATHON.
BACK TO HAVE YOU BACK AND GOOD
MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WANT TO GET TO THE NEW STORY
ABOUT A NUCLEAR PROGRAM IN A
MOMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN REPORT
ABOUT THE VARIOUS CASES OF
COVID POPPING UP IN CHINA?
>> WELL BILL, FOR 18 MONTHS NOW
WE HAVE HAD A BREAKDOWN IN
U.S./CHINA COOPERATION IN
TRACKING THE VIRUS AND
ANALYZING VARIOUS SAMPLES SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PHONE CALL IN
JANUARY LAST YEAR TO XI AND HIM
SAYING I DON’T WANT AMERICAN
SCIENTISTS COMING HERE.
HARD TO VERIFY OR CORROBORATE
STORIES COMING OUT.
WORST CASE CHINA IS REALLY
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THIS AND
KNOW ABOUT IT AND DELIBERATELY
LYING.
BEST CASE IT WAS A MISTAKE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO HELP
THEM.
HE SAID IN FEBRUARY OF LAST
YEAR THIS COULD HAVE BEEN A
MISTAKE IN THE LAB.
HE IS TRYING TO OPEN THE WAY
FOR XI TO GET OUT OF THIS
COVER-UP.
THE CHINESE WOULD NOT TAKE THE
HINT.
THEY ARE STILL ON THE ORIGINAL
PROPAGANDA LINE THAT THIS MAY
HAVE COME FROM AMERICA.
THAT IT DIDN’T COME FROM CHINA.
QUITE A WHOPPER TO BELIEVE.
>> Dana: WHAT CHINA SAYS.
A HOUSE REPUBLICANS PUT OUT THE
REPORT ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
COVID SUGGESTING THAT VERY
THING AND THIS IS WHAT CHINESE
FOREIGN MINISTRY SAID.
THE RELEVANT REPORT BASED ON
THE CONCOCTED LIES AND
DISTORTED FACTS WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY EVIDENCE IS NOT
CREDIBLE OR SCIENTIFIC.
THIS FEBRUARY A CHINA W.H.O.
TEAM VISITED THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
MEMBERS SPOKE HIGHLY OF THE
OPENNESS AND TRANSPARENCY AND
REACHED A MAJOR CONCLUSION THE
JOINT STUDY REPORT THAT THE
ALLEGATION OF LAB LEAKING IS
EXTREMELY UNLIKELY.
THEY HANG THEIR HAT ON THAT
EXPERTISE.
>> RIGHT.
I DON’T AGREE WITH THE CHINESE
SPOKESMAN.
MIKE MCCAUL OF TEXAS, HIS
REPORT WAS NOT BASED ON LIES OR
MADE UP.
HE ASSEMBLED A LOT OF THE
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE AND SHOWED
IT’S PLAUSIBLE.
HE COULDN’T PROVE IT BUT
PLAUSIBLE IT CAME FROM THE LAB.
COULD HAVE BEEN A MISTAKE OR
SOMETHING MORE SINISTER.
THEY DISMISS ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THE PROBLEM IS ON OUR SIDE, DR.
FAUCI AND HIS TEAM AT NIH NEED
TO PROVIDE A CHRONOLOGY OF WHAT
EXACTLY THEY’VE BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WITH THE
WUHAN LABORATORY.
A LOT MORE TO BE REVEALED FROM
THE AMERICAN SIDE.
THAT’S WHAT CONCERNS ME.
WE SHOULDN’T BE IMITATING THE
CHINESE SILENCE APPROACH.
DR. FAUCI SHOULD PROBABLY HAVE
A FAIRLY SERIOUS PRESS
CONFERENCE AND EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Bill: THAT COUNTRY HAS 144
MEDIUM AND HIGH-RISK AREAS, THE
MOST SINCE THE OUTBREAK.
I GUESS LATE 2019.
DESCRIBED AS THE DELTA VARIANT
BUT WHO KNOWS?
WE’LL SEE WHETHER OR NOT THAT’S
THE CASE.
ANOTHER BIG STORY, A NUCLEAR
PROGRAM HAS BEEN DETECTED, A
SECOND SITE HAS BEEN LOCATED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE’RE
LEARNING ABOUT THIS PRIMARILY
IN WESTERN CHINA?
>> WELL, THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING THE
CHINESE HAVE JUMPED TO REBUT
AND MAKE FUN OF AND SAY THIS
APPROXIMATELY 250 HOLES IN THE
GROUND WITH KIND OF A METAL
TENT ON TOP, THE CHINESE SAY IT
IS MINING CONSTRUCTION AND
NOBODY SHOULD BE WORRIED.
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT HASN’T TAKEN
AN AUTHORITATIVE POSITION YET.
THE IMPLICATION IS THEY COULD
BE DOUBLING OR TRIPLING THE
NUMBER OF H BOMBS THEY HAVE
TARGETED ON AMERICAN CITIES.
WE DON’T HAVE MISSILE DEFENSE
AGAINST CHINESE ICBMs.
WE LIMIT OUR MISSILE DEFENSE TO
IRAN AND NORTH KOREA.
WE WOULD HAVE TO START A MAJOR
PROGRAM TO ENHANCE OUR MISSILE
DEFENSE IF THE CHINESE ICBM
SILOS ARE REAL.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT IT, FRANKLY.
>> Dana: IT DOES SEEM LIKE IT
IS WORRISOME.
TO YOUR POINT WE DON’T HAVE THE
DEFENSE.
LAST QUESTION FOR YOU.
OCTOBER 31st, I BELIEVE, IS
WHEN JOE BIDEN AND THE REST OF
THE G-20 ALLIES AND CHINA WILL
BE TOGETHER.
DO YOU THINK THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN OUGHT TO HAVE SOME SORT
OF A STRATEGY GOING INTO THAT
MEETING TO DEAL WITH THIS VERY
THING?
>> I WOULD EXPECT MORE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY SAID A LOT OF HARSH THINGS
ABOUT CHINA WHEN THEY FIRST
CAME IN.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF SAID THAT
CHINA WAS NOT GOING TO SURPASS
AMERICA ON HIS WATCH.
THE SAME THING, DANA, THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP USED TO SAY.
SO FAR THEY HAVE NOT OUTLINED A
REAL STRATEGY THAT GOES POINT
BY POINT HOW TO COUNTER CHINA.
THEY SEEM TO PUT THINGS ON
ALLIES AND PARTNERS LIKE THE
JAPANESE AND INDIANS WILL COME
TO OUR AID.
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES ARE MORE
INTIMIDATED BY CHINA THAN WE
ARE.